[Music]
reportedly the Trump administration is
Wayne legal actions and options over
allegations that China hoarded critical
medical supplies to intentionally corner
the market on the stuff a senior legal
advisor to the president telling the New
York Post people are dying when you have
intentional cold-blooded premeditated
action like you have with China this
would be considered first-degree murder
here to weigh in Fox News contributor
and former South Carolina congressman
trey Gowdy congressman good morning to
you apparently this New York stood this
New York Post story during the month of
January executives from 3m and Honeywell
we're told they could not export any of
their mass and PPE out of China and at
the same time China was gathering things
from Asia and South America and the EU
as well nobody knew what was going on in
China had they known they probably
wouldn't have sent that stuff because
everybody else needed it you know you
got a couple of options Steve there are
international entities whether it's the
United Nations the World Health
Organization there's the International
Court of Justice they're actually trees
that that govern the interactions
between countries as it relates to
infectious disease but those are
toothless you've got American courts but
you got to get around the foreign
sovereign immunity act and then if you
get around that you got you got proof
problems I mean how is an individual
Americans supposed to get information
from China what the rest of the world
cannot the Trump administration doesn't
need to go to court a whole China
accountable you can hit them where it
hurts the most you can ostracize them on
the world stage quit letting their
students come here and study you can
make them a pariah but most importantly
you can start deducting the amount of
money we owe them and other countries Oh
them deduct our costs including the loss
of life but but all the other costs
start deducting that and then see what
China's reaction is yeah well that's
one way to do it you know but
congressman so many people have been
blaming China over the last couple of
weeks
hey why why didn't you tell us back in
January what was actually going on cuz
then with the rest of the world would
have had a heads up that's a great
question
the issue I have is where do we go to
get the answer to that question and if
you go to the United Nations China has
veto remember the South China Seas where
we complain that China was was building
military bases on the land they didn't
own we won in court and China said we
don't care so if they don't respect the
international treaties and entities and
they're immune from suit in our courts
we don't have much of an option except
administration to administration I
understand the presidency it says he has
a good relationship with the president
of China that's great we should have no
trouble getting compensation for the
Americans that have lost their lives and
lost their livelihoods if in fact we
have a good relationship with them and
so since then since January when China
was hoarding all this stuff over there
you know this country has been
scrambling to try to get more stuff and
last week the president invoked the
defense production act and told 3m they
got a they got to make more stuff well
last night we heard from the president
and he said that that has been solved
they are working with us and they're
going to come up with something like a
hundred and sixty seven million masse
over the next three months see that's
the way the defense production act is
supposed to work and the president has
judiciously only used it with
corporations and companies who aren't
cooperating with the with the country
it's like you don't want to help us all
right I'm gonna have to play hardball
right and I think the best remedy of all
Steve is to no longer have to rely on
that act and and the best way to not
rely is for American manufacturers to
make the things we need for our national
security so then you can argue that that
motorbikes and some other things are
luxuries but pharmaceuticals and
protective gear are not luxuries that is
a national security issue so
maybe the answer is for the United
States to be less dependent upon other
countries for things that keep us from
dying that that that obviates the need
to rely on an act and then we don't have
to ask anyone to do anything that
they're not currently doing because
we're already making the stuff in this
country I think that's the long-term
answer that comes out of this pandemic
you know what congressman Gowdy I think
people all across the country just heard
you say that and they go that's exactly
the solution we can't ever get stuck
like this again so thank you very much
for joining us today yes sir take care
of yourself right